qu'est-ce que je peux faire au moins
deux sympathiques mois écouter thierry
prenons les problèmes dans l'ordre
regardons le premier reproche les gens
disent thierry ardisson et lointains par
le faux souris faux je n'ai pas assez
proche des gens brown a deuxième
reproche on dit ardisson n'est pas
généreux on dit il roule pour ça qu'est
ce qu'ils en savent les gens les gens le
disent thierry yeux moi je regarde les
enquêtes je vous demande pas de comment
il a bien lutté chaque point les gens
disent ils s'intéressent qu'à lui-même
il se fiche du rech
alors à votre place je ferais un geste
là encore pour montrer que vous avez un
coeur coin dont par exemple
bon je fais un don
tarif vous prenez les français pour des
imbéciles en dont il s'en sert sur un
plateau télévisé le prenaient pour des
idiots alors on dit je fais un don et
puis dans 25 minutes on ira tous
dépensées en boîtes de nuit
si vous voulez faire un don regardez les
gens et fait un don maintenant en direct
devant tout le monde
bon mais comme un point commun porte mon
carnet de chèques s'il vous plaît il est
dans la poche de mon imperméable
vous allez donner à qui il faut que je
vous le dise à qui je donne sinon si
c'est si c'est pour me donner à moi de
gérer ça s'appelle pas un bon écoutez je
vais donner à la paroisse de man de mon
quartier voilà c'est un philippe du
roule catholique sais pas si c'est ce
que vous avez trouvé de mieux pour vous
rendre sa pratique m'a pas donné donné
donné à l'erythrée de fait puisque t'es
pas parce que sinon on va y passer deux
heures il donnera rien du tout vous
allez donnez combien 10000 autorités
jusqu'à 15000 en fait donné des mines
vale et non par rapport à ce que vous
gagnez jusqu'à imiter 15000 aura été
très justes noces de lédignan ok ben
écoute et thierry je crois qu'on a déjà
un petit peu remonté la pente en tout
cas j'ai un geste vers ce prélable voilà
je vous laisse poursuivre l'émission je
crois qu'on est ça va mieux là mon image
à mon sens ça s'améliore attendait tout
le travail ne sera pas en un jour
parce qu'on vient de loin loin d'avoir
loin loin que je dois vous remercier
je suis là pour vous donner des conseils
au vert cela j'ai mon expérience et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux